pour terminer ce journal coup de chapeau
et bienvenue à une petite soeur ou une
petite cousine qui ne demande qu'à
devenir grande la cinquième est né à 18h
sur l'ancien réseau de l'a5 début
officiel des programmes demain matin à
partir de 6h15 et tous les jours jusqu'à
19h chaîne éducative et populaire
patricia charnolé des enfants venus de
toute la france pour inaugurer la
cinquième au louvre
car c'est d'abord pour eux que cette
nouvelle chaîne a été fabriquée en six
mois sa mission expliquer le monde
améliorer l'information des jeunes
trouver des solutions pour l'emploi et
des rats la tolérance et à la
compréhension mutuelle il n'y aura de
l'ispor lives ariete sur la 5ème mais
une succession des missions courtes une
sorte de grand album d'image où chacun
ira chercher ce qu'il vaut par exemple
les sciences la médecine les langues les
nouvelles technologies histoire les
métiers
moi j'ai la vie devant moi et quand je
serai grand je serai heureux le monde il
nous changera pas c'est moi qui changera
lourd
alors c'est vrai tu veux faire pompiers
quand il sera grand alors viens avec moi
je vais te montrer